we're following that breaking news
tonight fire crews on the scene battling
a house fire on the east side of the
valley happening off of sahara right
near hollywood close to las vegas high
school joe mohler is there and joins us
now live with an update joe
yeah we're in the sunrise mobile home
estates we have learned from fire
officials that one person has died along
with three dogs we'll give you a live
look here at the scene several fire
crews and police are here in this mobile
home community as the fire investigation
continues we do have video as well some
video we shot here and also some drone
footage shot from a nearby neighbor fire
crews got here at four night got the
call at 419 that is of a double wide
trailer that was engulfed in flames
they got here around 4 35 and were able
to knock down the blaze and they were
unfortunately found one person inside
along with those three dogs now the fire
was contained to that one mobile home so
it did not spread to any nearby mobile
homes here but the street where this
happened is blocked off as this
investigation does continue
unfortunately one person has died so
cruz will be out here for some time
continuing this investigation but we are
expecting an update from officials as
well here in the near future so we'll be
updating you when we do get more
information reporting live joe mohler
live local now